welcome back vip auto center the sponsor
of this next segment is ready to help
across the valley if you need any auto
work done their family is here for yours
[Music]
hey folks it's bob myers i'm at vip
store number two today decatur and craig
here we do 1499 oil changes 14.99 smogs
we do everything from a to z in repairs
we're not your average automotive repair
facility we take pride in finding the
best techs in vegas
and all these guys behind me they can do
anything and they take pride in what
they do they want to make sure
it comes in broke it goes out fixed we
do free brake inspection
free safety inspection free ac
inspection and at all the locations
we do everything from your simplest oil
change strut shocks
tires heavy line repair computer
diagnostic we work on electric cars we
work on all your gas vehicles we work on
all your diesel vehicles no matter how
big or how small we take pride in what
we do
we're family-run family-owned
and uh we want our customers to feel
that when they come in
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you know people don't have a lot of
money these times you know we're not in
it for the money we're in it for you
know a living we're in it to do it we
work with everybody's budget um we also
offer free toes
to our customers at any of our three
locations we have one location on sahara
one on charleston and one on decatur
where we're at right now vfp cares about
the community we're community first you
know vegas strong
um all of our first responders active
duty military automatically get a 20
discount uh teachers same thing
we do uh weekly emails letting our
customers know that you know we're
having a special this week for you you
can visit us on our website or give us a
call come on down and be a part of our
family
well thank you to vip auto center for
sponsoring that segment they have three
locations across the valley for more
information head to vip auto service
center lv.com and they're offering 14.99
smog checks and oil changes and want to
remind you that they accept all fleet
accounts and they work with most
aftermarket and extended warranties las
vegas now will be